[Music]
hello good evening welcome to bombing in
that situation have you got a table pick
cv+ shake there be cool even in Lucas
table for two if you just like to follow
me
[Music]
I'm sure maybe okay he started selling
to wait time for your hands so have you
been here before - mommy daddy Shh -
well welcome to emigration and as you
see we've got your menu there so what
we've got for starters is cheesy nachos
and then followed by checking in - my
name is mommy and I'll be your reaches
for today and you and your new treat
tonight because you have the head shape
so we'll get that for you
I believe in gentlemen I'm your head
chef and I'm daddy believe you ordered
the day cook and the loser and they had
some special win tonight this is from
the Robinsons as elf special Wayne this
is Robinson Jose Arif it's a 20 to 20
it's from our Apple and blackcurrant
reserve if I just like to put a little
glass for you sorry about anything okay
no you something all the waitress I
belong just a minute to take you either
okay just bought a bleep air horn okay
there for you yeah enjoy the nachos good
no need anything just get maybe shape
hey does that party
maybe confusion Joey like the bags do
well past accomplish a thing
thank you so much I would you like
company before you have your quesadilla
really tasty Savita videos no problem
I'll get the champagne order to that for
you
good evening gentlemen have your main
course here Thank You mr. quesadilla a
boy or a girl kiss off which means that
Spanish chicken and cheese and our
special hangs south so they are also
known as ketchup and for you sir please
enjoy
have a good night yes and related for
dessert yes sir okay so our choices this
evening are vanilla ice cube with toffee
sauce mint chocolate chip ice cream or a
strawberry too late for some vanilla ice
cream and I'm sure our ass this year
I don't see that being answerable I
don't get ice Jack to you yes okay thank
you
there are gentlemen hope you enjoy the
meal strawberry ice lollies for yourself
syrup and some mint chocolate with
vanilla and sauce enjoy they recorded
mom and dad tonight you don't need to be
a painting
[Music]